talk about this one
killer gm's
from norway really
wow
this person is really from norway i
should know know who they are
anyway last game of the day
what is knight c3
okay i'll go c5 then
i feel like the knight the rat wouldn't
have worked very well there
oh it's uh it's a grumpy
attack no it's not a gravity attack it's
uh
it's close to ceiling of some sort
regardless of what it is
its positions are are usually quite
quite fine for for black
going for a flexible setup here
with the bishop b7 and
one big idea here is that d4 is usually
met
by by f5
staking
um serious claim in the center and
you're nipping white's ideas in the
budget
here also d5 is a serious
idea so i do believe that white should
normally go bishop
f2 or bishop the g1 here
now i think d5 is pretty good
um you usually want to meet this with e5
close up the center when you cannot do
that
then this means that i'm going to ha
i'm going to be able to go d4 and
he couldn't actually answer d4 with
d for after the bishop moves because the
queen would be hanging
and this means that he would would have
been in serious trouble there
even here i think positionally i'm
already
quite a bit better um
yeah and this doesn't actually help with
bishop h2 i think now knight d1 is
probably
probably forced since here i'm just
getting a
massive massive square run on e3
um yeah once the rook moves i'm going
i'm going to go f5 now
um even accidentally here trapped is on
on knight if knight g5 there's h6
and uh i really love my position here
it's just
a picture of complete um complete
harmony um you might want to see
rook on the e file but apart from that
i'm really just perfectly mobilized
and in that sense it's not a surprise
that
the tactics work out as well and that
i'm already completely winning here
so i'm just going eight six apart from
losing a piece here
um or yeah rather a a night
there are also serious serious
positional problems here for
for my opponent i'll take on attack on
g2
now knight before he coming next
either with with jack or uh
just attacking the rook and queen d5
and uh there's a lot of trouble there
brewing on the
long diagonal king f2 was probably the
best choice that he had there
but it wouldn't have helped now it's
i think a forced mate yeah it's a force
made key one queen h1
king of king h queen h turkey
f1 queen h1 king of two queen g2 queen
e1
and that queen is made
okay people i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
quit
uh with this decent game um
it's been a good ride and i hope to see
many many of you
for the tournament starting starting
sunday
so for until then take care